take two contrasting leaders President
George Bush whose policies I didn't like
and and President Barack Obama who
sometimes wasn't the greatest
administrator in the world but both of
them are people of character and they've
been true to who they are
I can disagree with their policies or I
can disagree with the way they run the
government but doesn't mean they're not
people of character and I think they're
quite authentic unfortunately a lot of
times in politics with the high media
intensity and the long cycle we have I
mean right now in the middle of a
political campaign that's running
sixteen months 18 months that's way too
long about 6 weeks like the Brits do it
but in you do test people in that period
but you get into a lot of media playing
the media I'm not blaming the media I'm
just saying they play the media and it
creates a lot of attention they say dumb
things you know today's world everything
you say is going to come back to haunt
you everything I say in this show is
like recorded for all time to everything
I write in my new book discover your
tuner I've got to stand behind for all
time I could then I was wrong but you
know you said it I said it and it's with
you and so I I think I'd like to see
more authentic people running for
president and holding political office
unfortunately I think a lot of authentic
people leaders have gotten turned off by
the whole process Donald Trump is an
amazing phenomenon I didn't like you
know him especially didn't think he was
authentic when he was running his
companies because all about him was a
big ego trip with Donald and it's all
about charisma or even Fame charisma are
trying to look good trying to attract
people to you who's not about serving
other people and then he did The
Apprentice show and I didn't like the
approach I've got fired now he's running
for office
I don't even ever held an office in his
life so he certainly it's not credential
to be President of States I'd hate to
think his fingers on the nuclear bomb
that wouldn't worry me a whole lot but
actually he'll say one thing and then
say something totally different few
months later he says whatever suits him
and there's a lot of anger there towards
different group
and he really is dividing various groups
exact opposite what I believe I believe
we accept people for who they are if
you're born outside the United States if
you have if you're a different gender
different color different sexual
preference we accept people for who they
are it's what happens to the person
inside not attacking people and kind of
generically I think this is wrong and so
I'm not at all happy with the Donald
Trump phenomenon but I admit it's it's
attracted a lot of people and many other
people are angry at the government too
so he's attracting them